burning tires barricades and tear gas
canisters have been littering the
Capitals main roads since mid-october
thousands of people have rallied against
any attempt by president Alpha Conde to
stay in power for a third term the
government allowed them to march but
only on certain sanctioned routes many
of the protesters deviated and that's
when they say police opened fire and
it's claimed officers didn't stop there
police entered into the hospital and
they started shooting at us and tried to
take some young boys but we refused a
coalition of opposition groups calling
itself the National Front the defense of
the Constitution has been spearheading
the marches it's now called for a
general strike to continue but in the
capital Conakry those with businesses
are paying the price unfortunately today
I didn't even get a client so I don't
know how the family is going to eat the
government is supposed to help us but
now the police are entering our houses
looting and hurting our children shops
markets and garages are all affected by
the strike with a rise in fuel prices
and inflation almost some double figures
many businesses say they are struggling
to survive mister customers come but
very few because there is no security
everybody is afraid of the police and
government 81 year old Conde first came
to power in 2010 his second and final
five-year term in office is coming to an
end this year the opposition says he
plans to use a new constitution to
extend his two-term limit and fears that
without the support of Parliament he may
go straight for a referendum it's
unclear when the strike and protests
will end that's likely to depend on
Condes next move Laura burden manley al
jazeera